President Trump gives a blockbuster
State of the Union address Stacey Abrams
responds and Bernie babbles I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
today we're gonna go through in detail
the State of the Union address the
responses from Bernie Sanders and from
Stacey Abrams and a brief response from
Camilla Harris we're gonna go through
all of that plus the media are obsessed
with Nancy Pelosi clapping because when
President Trump gives a good speech the
story is that Nancy Pelosi sat behind
him ruffling through papers and clapping
it was - Wow
just the unbelievable clapping of Nancy
Pelosi we'll get to all of that in just
one second first let's remember I know
nobody talks about this today but you
know our national debt is really really
large in 2008 the US national that was
10 trillion dollars today the debt is 22
trillion it is rising like a hockey
stick if you don't think we're sitting
on a house of cards you're living with
your head in the sand but since you're
listening to my podcast you are clearly
smarter than the average American so
what is your plan can you afford another
hit to your retirement like the last
downturn when the S&P dropped 50% it's
good to hedge against inflation and
hedge against uncertainty and
instability with a little bit of
diversification into precious metals
gold is a safe haven against uncertainty
my savings plan is diversified and yours
should be as well the company I trust
with precious metal purchases is Birch
gold group and right now thanks to a
little-known RS tax while you can even
move your IRA or eligible 401k into an
IRA backed by physical gold and silver
which is perfect for folks who want to
protect their hard-earned retirement
savings from any future geopolitical
uncertainty if it's something that
you're looking to if you're looking to
hedge against inflation then gold
safeguard savings I mean it's just a
well-known thing Birch gold group has
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews a plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
contact Birch gold group right now get a
free information kit
on physical precious metal see if
diversifying into gold and silver makes
sense for you ask all your questions get
that comprehensive 16-page kit find out
how you can legally move your IRA or
401k
out of stocks and bonds into a precious
metals IRA if that's something you're
interested in to get that no-cost
no-obligation kit text Ben two four
seven four seven four seven again text
Ben and that's my name - 47 47 47 do
that right now
go check out Birch gold really good
folks ok so last night the president
gives a State of the Union address as
you recall from yesterday's show I was
looking forward to the State of the
Union address the way that I normally
look for
to a root canal it's just not my thing I
don't like the State of the Union
address I think it's a man ARCIC stupid
institution I think it's full of silly
theatrics last night's was uniquely
entertaining for a variety of reasons
the number one reason it was uniquely
entertaining is because every State of
the Union address we get the game of who
stands up who sits down who claps whoo
cheers how do people respond and the
Democrats did I thought a pretty
horrendous job of responding to
president Trump's speech it seems that
they had a basic rule which is they were
not going to clap for anything and then
Nancy Pelosi and all of her wisdom might
lead them once in a while and clapping
but president Trump successfully made
them look silly in what they chose to
clap for and what they did not choose to
clap for meanwhile he gave what was one
of the best speeches of his career now
it was delivered with typical Trump sort
of half interest because he was reading
from a teleprompter all of his best
moments came when he was off
teleprompter when he was sort of riffing
with the room or something would happen
and then he'd drop a funny line and what
was weird about the the entire event is
that we live in an extraordinarily
politically divided time but it was kind
of a feel-good speech you came away from
the speech thinking okay well that was
kind of nice right like everybody seemed
to get along and maybe the country isn't
in that much trouble which is what Trump
was going for so let's jump right into
president Trump's State of the Union
address the theme of his address was
choosing greatness that was the the
overarching theme and his basic idea was
that America not only should be great
again but also America has been great in
the past and this is a narrative that
Trump is on solid ground in talking
about because there really are two
visions of what America is and has been
there's the Republican vision the
conservative vision which says America
was founded on eternal truths and
guiding principles we haven't always
lived up to those but we have always
moved toward the better in fulfillment
of those principles and we have freed
millions of people from slavery and
depredation we have freed billions of
people from poverty in other words
America is a pretty freaking phenomenal
place America is a phenomenal place and
our shortcomings are attempt to correct
those shortcomings is part of that story
right the fact that we have not always
lived up to our best principles and that
we have tried to correct ourselves
that's because we are so incredible
then there's the Democrat vision of the
United States founded in racism sexism
bigotry patriarchal ism and we have
gradually moved away from that founding
toward a better future but we're not
there yet
in America still kind of a hellhole and
therefore we need to continue fighting
to overcome our past that's that sort of
the democratic vision one is the vision
of a people that was founded on good
ideas and we're constantly trying to
better ourselves to live up to those
ideas and one was the idea and one is
the sort of America was founded in sin
rooted in sin can never escape that sin
Trump laid out that contrast pretty
nicely last night
more than anything Democrats laid out
that contrast when they refused to clap
for basically obvious ideas about
America so here's President Trump last
night talking about choosing greatness
we must choose between greatness or
gridlock results or resistance vision or
vengeance incredible progress or
pointless destruction tonight I ask you
to choose greatness okay now it's
important to note that this speech was
much better written than a lot of his
other speeches so it's pretty obvious
Stephen Miller did not write the speech
Stephen Miller speeches are very are
very they're a replete with a dark
vision of America a vision of America
where it's carnage and chaos this speech
was all about America being pretty
awesome which as the incumbent president
president Trump needs to make the case
for you can see in the background if
you're watching this the Nancy Pelosi is
ruffling through sheets of paper which
by the way is kind of rude I mean if a
Republican had done that while President
Obama was president there'd be endless
talk about how condescending it was
Nancy Pelosi however was deeply
condescending last night and the media
cheered it the media coverage of the
State of the Union address which we will
get to in a little while here was as
stupid and nonsensical and partisan and
biased as any coverage I've ever seen in
the president which is to say it was
another day in American media President
Trump then started talking about how
unemployment rates have dipped to record
lows and again Democrats refuse to cheer
for record low unemployment rates you
you would figure that really that's bad
optics and what they'd really want to
say is yes unemployment rates have
dipped to record lows as part of the
continuing success of the Obama economy
right all you have to do just
politically is say the reason that the
economy has continued to boom is because
it was already doing well under Obama
and it has continued to do well under
President Trump not the end of the world
but Democrats couldn't even bring
themselves to cheer for low black
unemployment rates
has reached the lowest rate in over half
a century african-american Hispanic
American and Asian American unemployment
have all reached their lowest levels
ever recorded unemployment for Americans
with disabilities has also reached an
all-time low okay Nancy Pelosi is
sitting there not cheering and there are
the Democrats sitting there not standing
up not cheering so is it a bad thing
that people with disabilities are
working weird weird okay so the
Democrats were refusing to cheer for low
unemployment rates they also definitely
refused to cheer for putting sex
traffickers out of business which is a
weird look so President Trump says now
it's time for America to end sex
trafficking it's time for America to end
illegal immigration that involves human
trafficking and the Democrats are
sitting there like no we like human
trafficking now obviously they don't
like human trafficking but they don't
want to give President Trump any sort of
win here even if what he's speaking
about is a basic principle of being a
human so watch this now is the time for
Congress to show the world that America
is committed to ending illegal
immigration and putting the ruthless
coyote's cartels drug dealers and human
traffickers out of business
and then there's Pamela Harris shaking
her head up that's terrible putting sex
traffickers out of business Wow she's a
tough prosecutor you know she's a tough
prosecutor who really cares about crime
rates she's so tough that she shakes her
head when we talk about putting sex
traffickers out of business como eres
what a delight she is okay so the
Democrats definitely showing like Trump
should just run endless commercials in
2020 of him saying eminently obvious
things and Democrats shaking their heads
or refusing to clap that's a pretty good
commercial for him against Kamala Harris
we want to put sex traffickers out of
business
and calm lahars like no no we don't know
let's not do that
shaking my head ruefully just terrible
and then President Trump got to his
illegal immigration pitch in which he
said correctly the tolerance for illegal
immigration is cruel because what you
actually want is lots of legal
immigrants and illegal immigration comes
with severe human cost now this was
pretty amazing once again Democrats
refuse to acknowledge that he is correct
that people are damaged in transit when
they are brought in by coyotes so here
is president from speaking about it
tolerance for illegal immigration is not
compassionate it is actually very cruel
one in three women is sexually assaulted
on the long journey north smugglers use
migrant children as human pawns to
exploit our laws and gain access to our
country now one of my favorite media
fact checks occurred in about this line
of the speech the president Trump said
one in three women is sexually assaulted
on the long journey north statistics
suggest that 31% of women are sexually
assaulted on the long journey north
which is about one in three Ramon's
pretty close to one in three so the fact
checker said partly true partly
fact-check partly true so in other words
33% is one and three it was 31% he said
one in three and they rated it partly
true because the fact checkers are so
full of it the fact checkers are just
terrible I mean the fact checks of the
State of the Union address are so absurd
a woman at the New York Times you'll see
later the president Trump suggests that
a Jew who was freed from Dachau a death
camp during the Holocaust saw American
soldiers coming from the sky and thought
they came from heaven and a fact-checker
from the New York Times said Jews don't
believe in heaven say well you had one
job guys we sort of do
we sorted to do president from
continuing he talked about walls working
he spends an awful lot of time in the
speech talking about illegal immigration
and then his conclusion was walls work
which obviously is his main campaign
pitch because in about a week and a half
here we're gonna go into possible second
government shutdown or him declaring a
national emergency so here's him making
that case simply put walls work and
walls save lives so let's work together
compromise and reach a deal that will
truly make America safe okay and the
Democrats want to cheer for that so we
have to recap Democrats will not cheer
for making America safe through
compromise Democrats will not cheer for
low unemployment for blacks Hispanics
Asian Americans and Americans with
Disabilities Americans that they will
not cheer for ending sex trafficking
what will you ask yourself what will
Democrats cheer for what do Democrats
what do they like and it turns out that
what Democrats will cheer for is
themselves they love themselves just
like Jim Acosta loves Jim Acosta
Democrats love themselves and Democrats
it was an appalling display it this was
truly appalling so President Trump talks
about high employment among women and I
guess we're not allowed to cheer for
black black employment or Hispanic
employment or Asian employment or just
disabled people employment we are able
to cheer only for people with vaginas
employment although maybe that's
overstated because some men are women is
we've learned so people who identify as
women employment that we are allowed to
cheer for because women are so put upon
in American society women have it so
rough in American society we say as we
look at the Speaker of the House who is
a woman sitting behind the President of
the United States during the State of
the Union address I'm gonna play you
these self-serving gross congratulatory
nonsense that the Democrats participated
in last night it made them look
particularly bad and it exposed their
vision of America that is false and
truly morally off-putting I mean I was
really off foot by this and I think a
lot of people work I'll show you in just
one second first let's talk about the
underwear that grace ER took us at this
very moment if your big Valentine's Day
surprise consists of sushi from the
grocery store it's time for you to
rethink what a Valentine's Day gift can
be with Tommy John the most comfortable
underwear for everyone on the planet
it's a gift that's not only unexpected
but genuinely needed Tommy John is
redefining comfort for men and women
luxuriously soft feather-light
moisture-wicking underwear that moves
with you not against you with no
pinching no punching no riding up it's
no wonder Tommy John has sold over 6
million pairs no wedgies either which
would have been super helpful to me in
high school if you're still looking for
a Valentine's Day gift they're limited
edition loungewear an underwear
including matching his and her sets are
the perfect alternative to boring and
played out cliche gifts last year the
limited edition collection sold out in
less than a week so do not wait until
the last minute with Tommy John's best
pair you'll ever wear or it's free
guarantee if you don't love that first
pair you get a full refund so there is
no excuse not to buy the gift of comfort
they truly deserve shop limited-edition
Valentine's Day gift sets right now get
20% off your first order at Tommy John
comm / Ben that's Tommy John comm / Ben
go check it out right now Tommy John
comm / Ben for 20% off only at Tommy
John comm at Tommy John calm I know it's
great because it is upon my tuchus at
this very instant Tommy John comm / Ben
for 20% off ok so the key moment of the
entire night president Trump has been
unable to unify the Democrats and the
Republicans about anything President
Trump has been unable to get Democrats
to clap for anything up to and including
more black people Hispanic people Asian
people and people with disabilities
working they will not share for anything
but then he stumbles on the one thing
Democrats will cheer for Democrat women
will cheer for these fighters for the
underclass what will they cheer for
themselves so here was this self
congratulatory girl power bachelorette
party nonsense that happened at the
State of the Union address last night
no one has benefited more from our
thriving economy than women who have
filled 58% of the newly created jobs
last year all Americans can be proud
that we have more women in the workforce
than ever before and exactly one century
after Congress passed the constitutional
amendment giving women the right to vote
we also have more women serving in
Congress than at any time before
and there they are curing themselves yay
we love us were the best aoc turns
around and she actually gives an air
high-five to know on it really that
happens they're cheering they're dancing
they're there they're so happy about
they love them my goodness the obstacles
they've overcome my goodness what a
place America is because these women
were elected okay this is off-putting
garbage
the reason it's off-putting garbage is
because if we are going to talk about
the privileges that people have been
given in the United States it is a
privilege to be born a woman in the
United States today America is the
freest country in world history the most
upwardly mobile country for women in
world history this notion that women are
uniquely put upon in American society is
sheer statistical nonsense it is just
not true and not only is it not true not
true the the absurdity of these women
declaring themselves heroes look at what
we've achieved look at what we've done
because look how great look how much
we've had over what has AOC had to
overcome like a thing I'm not asking
like many things I'm asking like a thing
she's a 29 year old bartender with no
credentials and no capacity to
understand basic economics she sits in
Congress and it's extraordinarily famous
what's the obstacle she had to overcome
why are we cheering this as though this
is something unique in American life as
though she is the she's breaking a glass
ceiling it's just not true it's just not
true and it does show the vision that
the Democrats have for the country okay
I want to talk about this in just a
second Democrats see America is a very
different place than Republicans see
America so as I say Republicans see
America as a place with eternal truths
truth like we are all created equal in
the eyes of God like we all have equal
rights and we've imperfectly applied
that rule but we have moved toward the
application of that rule women were
given the vote more than a century ago
hey women have been in politics for a
very long time women constitute the
majority of voters they constitute the
majority of college graduates they
constitute the vast majority of people
who gain new jobs in the current
economic upsurge women have had more
wage mobility in the last thirty years
than men have in the United States women
are not victims and this notion that
Democrats are pushing that women have
overcome now because lots of women were
elected to Congress oh look at us we are
just so awesome it's so funny AOC will
say that she has cisgender privilege
that she had because she's a cisgender
woman she has privilege we all have to
acknowledge our privilege white
privilege and and and male privilege the
privilege of the patriarchy but nobody
in the Democratic Party will acknowledge
the greatest privilege of all which is
that they stands on the shoulders of
people who actually made sacrifices
people who actually had to overcome
people who actually were part of the
American story making America better
sitting around and championing ourselves
is overcoming some sort of victimhood
when you've experienced no victimhood is
a mark of ingratitude and nastiness
there are people in that room who had to
live through the civil rights movement
and actually did heroic work I'm talking
about people with whom I disagree
harshly on politics people like John
Lewis who actually had to live through
the civil rights movement and were and
were deeply influential in helping make
the country a better place those people
if you if you say John Lewis it's an
American Congress that's something to
cheer about
AOC sits in American Congress oh let's
cheer because women are in Congress now
I'm sorry there was nothing that was
overcome here nothing
there was no barrier to entry for for
women in Congress there is nothing
uniquely amazing about what just
happened in the last election I know
we're supposed to pretend that women
broke through a glass ceiling there was
no glass ceiling in American politics
Hillary Clinton won the popular vote in
the last election cycle she was
Secretary of State Condoleezza Rice was
Secretary of State Sarah Palin ran for
vice president Nancy Pelosi this is not
her first round as Speaker of the House
to Speaker of the House 12 years ago
can we stop pretending now that women
are massively victimized in American
society by the patriarchal hierarchy and
that the only thing worthy of cheering
is these Democrats cheering themselves
it shows an utter incredible ingratitude
you know President Trump spent a lot of
his speech last night we'll get to it
paying homage to the heroes of the past
who actually had to overcome obstacles
you know the people who stormed the
beaches of Normandy the civil rights
workers who had to be attacked by dogs
in order to try and gain the capacity to
even vote under the law they those are
heroes those are people you cheer you
don't cheer yourself just because you're
a woman and you happen to be in Congress
because you won 15,000 votes in a
primary against Joe Crowley in a
majority-minority district that does not
it doesn't wash and not only that it
promotes this this again this vicious
idea that America is still a place
filled with boundaries that must be
overcome particularly for women and that
is just it's just nonsense and it's
self-serving nonsense too
it it's so arrogant honestly to cheer
your own achievement when you haven't
achieved anything or at least if your
achievement is not in spite of a great
obstacle listen I am NOT somebody who's
had to overcome a lot of obstacles I've
never said I am I am grateful to live in
a country where I don't have the
obstacles of war and discrimination to
overcome I'm deeply grateful for that my
great privilege in the United States is
I have two great privileges one I grew
up with grandparents and two I grew up
in the greatest country in the history
of mankind bar none those are my
privileges my privilege is that I grew
up on the back of giants on the
shoulders of giants nobody in the
Democratic Party is willing to
acknowledge that the sacrifices of the
past mean nothing because America is
still a place filled with obstacles and
difficulties and it's so hard for women
in America it's just not true it's just
not true
frankly I'm kind of astonished at the
lack of intersectional understanding on
the part of these democratic women like
from a left perspective if you are going
to rank victimized groups in the United
States women come in close to last as a
victimized group in the United States if
you're gonna cheer anything and
celebrate anything presumably you would
be celebrating black employment rates
and the intersectional hierarchy black
ranks higher than female but the only
thing these Democrats were getting up in
cheering is oh we're women and girl
power and wow we've done something unit
you haven't done anything I'm sorry
you you haven't also there is a very
anti transgender element to all of this
which is if you believe that gender is a
social construct and why does it matter
whether women are elected to Congress or
not if gender is just something that we
made up then why are we cheering for
women being elected to Congress all of
this was really off-putting and it cut
against the and also it was a smart play
by Trump because now he's got a bunch of
women standing and cheering for him now
the media tried to unspin this the media
tried to say well they were kind of self
mocking Trump they were trying to mock
Trump because most of these women were
Democrats there's an idiotic fact check
that said President Trump said we have
more women serving in Congress than ever
before fact check they're all Democrats
did Trump say there were Republicans he
didn't write all this is is an attempt
to spin away from a bad optic moment for
the Democrats because again Democrats
will not stand for low black
unemployment rates but they will stand
for were awesome and we love us and here
we
are dancing and doing karaoke night in
the middle of Congress really
off-putting really kind of honestly kind
of morally despicable like patting
yourself on the back
well failing to you want to check your
priveledge check your priveledge ladies
check your priveledge you grew up in the
in the freest richest country in world
history the most free country for women
in world history check your priveledge
stop pretending that you did it yourself
you didn't build that as you might say
this was not you you didn't build it all
your forebears built it you might want
to think about that before you start
standing up and cheering for what what
wonderful things you've done when
legitimately you've done nothing except
run for office and then win
congratulations you're just like
everybody else in that chamber who ran
for office in one again president Trump
continued and then he got into the the
red meat section for for Republicans and
this is the first time I've ever heard
anybody in Republican politics say the
correct thing about abortion here was
the President of the United States going
on about abortion as was appropriate to
do one of the one of the only flaws in
this speech well there we'll get to the
bad stuff in the speech in a second but
one of the big flaws in the speech is
that a lot of the best material was back
loaded so he started off with this very
very long wind-up about how great things
are in America how unemployment is low
and this went on for a solid 35 to 40
minutes and then he finally got to the
part where he can throw punches and the
throwing of the punches was obviously
the best part Trump is a hammer you got
to let Trump be a hammer they did let
him do that last night and when he did
it it was great I'll get to that in just
a moment first let's talk about another
Valentine's Day gift that you should be
considering okay you should certainly be
considering 1-800 flowers icon this
one's a no-brainer
every time I travel I send my wife
flowers via 1-800 flowers calm because I
am that sort of husband you too can be
that sort of husband when you go to
1-800 flowers calm right now roses from
1-800 flowers are on sale if you order
early even get the 18 stem enchanted
Rose medley for $29.99 or order a double
for 36 stems enchanted roses for $20
more this is an unbelievable offer from
1-800 flowers again 18 stem enchanted
Rose medley for $29.99 or double the
roses for 20 bucks more which is a
spectacular deal they are amazing roses
really roses from 1-800 flowers they're
picked at their peak they're shipped
overnight to ensure freshness and her
amazement the 18 stem enchanted Rose
medley for
99 or double 236 roses for 20 bucks more
it's an amazing offer but it expires
today you have to do it like right now
because they are backlogged so you need
to order this right now to make sure the
Roses get there on time and you get
access to the deal to order that 18 stem
enchanted Rose medley for $29.99 or
double the roses for 20 bucks more go to
1-800 flowers calm / capiro that is
1-800 flowers calm / Shapiro's go check
it out right now
1-800 flowers calm / Shapiro's these
things stay fresh longer than the stuff
you get at the grocery store they are
high quality bouquet prices are going up
soon so you need to take advantage right
now at one eight hundred four scum / up
hero 1-800 flowers calm / Shapiro's okay
so then President Trump got to his punch
throwing section of the night and this
was wonderful
there was president from going after the
Democrats on abortion there could be no
greater contrast to the beautiful image
of a mother holding her infant child
then the chilling displays our nation
saw in recent days lawmakers in New York
cheered with delight upon the passage of
legislation that would allow a baby to
be ripped from the mother's womb moments
from birth these are living feeling
beautiful babies who will never get the
chance to share their love and their
dreams with the world and then we had
the case of the governor of Virginia
where he stated he would execute a baby
after birth to defend the dignity of
every person I am asking Congress to
pass legislation to prohibit the late
term abortion of children
let us work together to build a culture
that cherishes innocent life and let us
reaffirm a fundamental truth all
children born and unborn are made in the
holy image of God and Democrats sit
there nothing nothing of course of
course so lots of sharing for women
elected to Congress no cheering for
children are made in the image of God so
I think their priorities are obviously
in line one of the best moments of the
night was president from going after
socialism so whoever wrote his speech
did a great job with this because there
is a fault line in the Democratic Party
their depth most of the Democrats are
fine with the idea of sort of democratic
socialism along the lines of Bernie
Sanders or aoc they're fine with it
right they they like a lot of these
medicare-for-all ideas they just don't
want to admit it publicly and here is
the fault line a lot of Democrats who
are kind of the older wiser Democrats
understand Americans instinctively don't
like socialism that Americans think that
socialism is replete with economic
oppression and tyranny which of course
is true and so President Trump goes
directly after socialism and you have to
notice the variant responses of Nancy
Pelosi and aoc and Bernie so Trump is
about to rip into socialism and Nancy
Pelosi sits back there and gives like a
soft clap the soft clap because she has
to demonstrate to people that she is not
in favor of socialism and then there's a
slow pan in on Bernie Sanders as the
Curb Your Enthusiasm music plays in the
background and it's pretty spectacular
here in the United States we are alarmed
by the new calls to adopt socialism in
our country
[Music]
America was founded on liberty and
independence and not government coercion
domination and control we are born free
and we will stay free tonight we renew
our resolve that America will never be a
socialist country there's Nancy Pelosi
turning back around a little bit and
there's Bernie Sanders looking very
trepidatious I mean it's
listen I know Bernie's uncomfortable
he's only comfortable really when he's
shirtless singing in the USSR in the
1980s that's that's really where Bernie
is is most comfortable a Bernie looking
very uncomfortable there after a life of
uselessness in public life
being told that his dreams may not be
achieved President Trump also went after
Iran he talked about their anti-semitism
the Democrats refused to cheer for that
the best moment of the night honestly
the best moment of the night is when the
entire Congress sang happy birthday to a
Holocaust survivor what was great about
the speech is that it reminded Americans
that this is a great country I mean not
just a good country a great country the
greatest country in world history and
this was a great moment
it's a Holocaust survivor named Judas
Hammett he survived the tree of life
Massacre this year and today and
yesterday was his birthday the entire
Congress got up and sang him happy
birthday
think about that guy's life think about
this you grow up in Europe in a time of
Nazi oppression you are sent to a death
camp a concentration camp you are
liberated by American troops and then
you end up in Congress 6070 years later
after having survived a shooting by
white supremacists and the entire
Congress the elected officials of the
United States and you happy birthday
what an amazing country this is well
that that's what at this clip 10 here is
President Trump talking about Judas
Haman tonight we are also joined by
Pittsburgh survived Judah salmon he
arrived at the synagogue as the massacre
began but not only did Judah narrowly
escaped death last fall more than seven
decades ago he narrowly survived the
Nazi concentration camps
today is Judas 81st birthday
[Applause]
there's trump nothing I mean that that
is a great moment that's a great moment
and that this is an amazing country and
that was really the theme of Trump's
speech you know that again embrace
greatness this is a great country that
people who came before us are great it's
that latter point the Democrats refused
to acknowledge the people who came
before us had greatness in ways that we
don't have and we stand on their
shoulders that's what makes the country
great a little bit of gratitude would go
a long way but Democrats can't
acknowledge their American privilege
check your priveledge democrats
acknowledge your American privilege in a
second I don't get to the low point from
President Trump speech because there
were some there's a lot of great stuff
and there's a little bit of bad stuff so
we'll get to the bad stuff we will also
get to Stacey Abrams his response and
the execrable media response which is
just egregious as you would expect but
first let's talk about Sheree's berries
okay Valentine's Day this year I've
already talked to you about some gifts
you can get I will tell you something
that will astonish her okay I know this
because I just did this for my wife it's
unbelievable so Sheree's berries is
incredible they have kosher products I
brought some of those kosher products of
them my wife and my kids plowed through
that stuff like wow and it is delicious
okay I'm telling you this is some of the
best dessert you have ever had in your
life you'll never go wrong with their
signature dipped Valentine's
strawberries dipped in milk dark or
white chocolaty goodness for any
discerning palate she will fall in love
with every bite topped with decadent
toppings chocolate chips hearts glitter
sparkles always fresh always taste the
end they have other stuff too they're
kosher stuff it's like cookies covered
in chocolaty goodness and they've got
caramels covered in chocolate
I mean it's just on this stuff is unreal
it's some of the best dessert you will
ever have I am NOT just saying this
because they're an advertiser on the
program legitimately we went over to
somebody's house on Shabbat and we
didn't know what to bring them for a
gift and my wife after having had
Sherry's barish like there's only one
gift we can bring it's Sherry's berries
their Valentine's arrived fresh with
100% cherries berries guarantee should
be anywhere nationally giving something
sweet to your long-distance love right
now they're giving you the Valentine's
Day gift of your dreams starting at
$19.99 plus shipping and handling so
it's great not only are you getting
amazing amazing chocolaty goodness you
are also not spending a ton of money so
two of my favorite things great gifts
for not a huge price right now order and
you get
the berries for just ten bucks more go
to berries calm click on the microphone
enter my code Ben show at checkout
that is berries calm BER our IES calm
click the microphone and enter promo
code Ben show order today you're not
gonna regret it stuff's unreal it's so
good ok so we were gonna get to the rest
of President Trump speech Stacy a
boluses response you're gonna need to go
over to Taylor wire.com and subscribe
right now for the rest of that live so
last night we had a State of the Union
coverage party we had lots of people
watching only subscribers could ask the
questions we have two additional hours
of me everyday you're only gonna be able
to get on demand without commercials
when you become a subscriber so what are
you waiting for you need to go subscribe
right now for $9.99 a month over at
daily wire comm when you spend $99 a
year you also get this very greatest in
beverage vessels cast your eyes upon it
the leftist here is hot or cold tumblr
magnificent go check that out right now
also subscribe at YouTube or iTunes we
have a Sunday special coming out every
week all sorts of wonderful things just
for you become a subscriber and help
support us and make sure that we can say
what we want to say and when we need to
say it
go check us out right now at daily
wire.com we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
now I'd be remiss I have talked a lot
about a lot of the good stuff from Trump
speech and overall this was for
president term I thought it's the best
speech of his career it was certainly
the best written speech of his career
there were moments that he delivered
really really well president Trump on
teleprompter is better than President
Trump off teleprompter president from on
teleprompter punctuated by a couple of
jokes where he's playing to the audience
is great is great so there are a lot of
high points here if somebody this
morning described it as a grand slams me
I said it was a three-run homer the only
reason I'm not calling it a grand slam
is because President Trump did have some
some clunkers so a couple of his
clunkers he talked at one point about
how America is thriving and then in a
line that he clearly wrote himself he
decided to talk about congressional
investigations of him this was a real
clunker it was a mistake President Trump
should be saying listen I'm above these
investigations they can try and
investigate me up the wazoo they're not
gonna find anything this is this is all
witch-hunt do all of that but at the
State of the Union address trying to
suggest that the country is going to
fail if you are investigated looks
defensive and it looks as though you're
afraid of the investigations who's a
mistake president Trump did some of that
last night if there is going to be peace
and legislation there cannot be war and
investigation it just doesn't work that
way
and Republicans don't know whether to
clap or whether or not to clap because
the investigations are gonna go forward
no matter what this looked self-serving
and it was petty for the president it
was a bad moment for him okay other bad
moments he did talk at one point about
sentencing laws that he said wrongly and
disproportionately harmed the African
American community I think the evidence
for that is extraordinarily scanty and
it seems pandering to me another one of
his worst moments is when he suggested
that we'd be in the middle of a major
war with the North Koreans with
potentially millions killed here as
president Trump suggesting that if not
for him we'd now be in a shooting war
with it with Kim jong-un which is
obviously not true as part of a bold new
diplomacy we continue our historic push
for peace on the Korean Peninsula our
hostages have come home nuclear testing
has stopped and there has not been a
missile launch in more than 15 months
if I had not been elected president of
the United States we would right now
in my opinion be in a major war with
North Korea okay the evidence for that
is extraordinarily non-existent so a few
bad moments for president Trump
basically the places where you figure
Trump actually inserted the line himself
not great stuff but overall very good
speech for President Trump now the
Democratic response Stacy Abrams gives
the Democratic response
she's the failed Democratic
gubernatorial candidate in Georgia she's
a very talented speaker her delivery was
excellent
now what was weird about it just in
terms of optics is that she had a group
of apparently children of the corn
standing behind her during the speech
and poorly lit so it looked like they
were all in the shadows and she was
standing in front of them is a very kind
of weird optic she delivered the speech
really well but her message was
discordant so president Trump's entire
speech was about unity the greatness of
American history the fact that we stand
on the shoulders of giants and Stacey
Abrams his entire speeches about how
America is still a terrible horrible no
good very bad place and how nothing has
really changed from the past so she
started off by talking about the this is
always the divide in sort of democratic
thinking they want to say things like
America is the land of opportunity but
then they want to take it back so here's
her talking about how America is a land
of opportunity and then you'll hear her
take it back in a second our power and
strength as Americans lives in our hard
work and our belief in more my family
understood firsthand that while success
is not guaranteed we live in a nation
where opportunity is possible but we do
not succeed alone in these United States
when times are tough we can persevere
because our friends and neighbors will
come for us okay all of that is true
all of that is true but there's one
problem when she says you know when
times are tough we persevere because our
friends and neighbors come for us that's
true that's that's how the voluntary
Association everyone on the Republican
side of the aisle is in agreement with
that what Democrats want is for our
friends and neighbors not to come for us
they want the government to come for us
then she got to her real message and her
real message that America kind of blows
that America has got some real problems
and that America is kind of a sucky
place and for all of the talk about how
America's a land of opportunity it
really isn't for particular minority
groups Oh clip three she suggests that
voter suppression is real this is a law
voter suppression is not real blacks
represent a a well turned out group of
voters they over represents it in 2008
they over-represented in 2012 in 2016
black showed up to vote and precisely
the same rate as everybody else in the
Georgia race of blacks trope to vote an
extraordinarily high race the idea that
that votes were being suppressed in
Georgia there's no evidence to back this
this is just more evidence that Stacey
Abrams believes that she was wrongfully
deprived of a gubernatorial seat in
Georgia that she clearly lost Brian Kemp
won that seat he did and all of her lies
about how she was robbed of the seat are
just that their lives but here she is
again underscoring the idea that America
is kind of a crappy place let's be clear
voter suppression is real from making it
harder to register and stay on the rolls
to moving and closing polling places to
rejecting lawful ballots we can no
longer ignore these threats to democracy
okay and then she gets to her real point
which is that not much has changed and
this is the big issue again President
Trump says that things have changed in
the past because great people were there
in the past to help push change along
and we can be part of that history and
that America has always been a place
where good has overcome evil even if
it's taken too long in some cases Stacey
Abrams is cases that not much has
changed so here is here she is talking
about how America because it was rooted
in racism and sin can never really get
over that racism and sin and nothing has
changed if you really believe nothing
has changed in America since 1960 I
would just urge you to take a look at
Stacey Abrams who nearly became governor
of Georgia yes some of the things have
changed in the United States we fought
Jim Crow with the Civil Rights Act and
the Voting Rights Act yet who we
continue to confront racism from our
past and in our present which is why we
must hold everyone from the highest
offices to our own families accountable
for racist words and deeds and call
racism what it is wrong America achieves
a measure of reproductive justice in roe
v wade but we must never forget it is
immoral to allow politicians to harm
women and families to advance a
political agenda and this is her
intersectionality point that we
discussed on yesterday's show this is
this is her intersectionality idea that
policies she doesn't like our attacks on
specific minority groups and those
minority groups bus you know
in order to beat back those attacks it's
a lie it's untrue and it's a false
depiction of the United States so that's
a conflict divisions that we're gonna
see in 2020 president Trump talking
about how America is great has been
great is based on great ideals and
Democrats suggesting that America was
never great was filled with terror and
horror and continues to be filled with
terror and horror that can only be cured
when we recognize the intersectional
ideal but that's going to be the big
conflict in a second we're gonna get
into Bernie Sanders his responsibly
senator Sanders gave his response to the
State of the Union address last night
which made him a racist obviously
because you have people like Stacey
Abrams giving a speech that means that
he's stepping on a black woman by giving
his own State of the Union response
despite the fact this is the third
straight year he's done it again the
intersectional politics of the
Democratic Party is sick and it's it's
stupid counterproductive
Bernie supposedly did a very very bad
thing by speaking on the same night as
Stacey Abrams so Bernie's shtick was
basically socialism is great right so he
after being after being basically
scorched by President Trump in the State
of the Union then this crazy old loon
bag gets on TV and he suggests that
socialism is indeed great because
socialism already exists for wealthy
people which is a weird thing to say
this country has socialism for the rich
and rugged individualism for the poor
weird how did the poor people become
rich I mean let's assume that he's right
let's assume that when you're when
you're really rich that you get the
benefit of certain government programs
which obviously is untrue by the way the
rich pay an enormous amount in taxes the
poor pay virtually nothing in the United
States the rich pay all net taxes they
don't get any benefits back from the
government the poor pay no taxes and get
tremendous tax benefits from the
government they get all sorts of welfare
benefits from the government let's
assume for a second that he wasn't lying
which I know it's a big assumption when
he says the country has socialism for
the rich and rugged individualism for
the poor weird because lots of poor
people become rich so what made them
rich was it the socialism or the rugged
individualism interesting interesting
and then he said people are not truly
free until they get a bunch of free
stuff from the government because
freedom is stuff yeah this is an
interesting take and and does
demonstrate the wide variance between
the left's view of rights and the rights
view of rights people are not truly free
when they can't afford to go to the
doctor when they are sick
people are not truly free when they
cannot afford to buy the prescription
drugs they desperately need people are
not truly free when they are unable to
retire with dignity okay so this is the
Marxist credo the Marxist credo is if we
give you a bunch of stuff and you have a
bunch of material stuff now you're free
but when you're poor you are not free
the right says you're free when people
are not oppressing you you're free when
people are not setting the rules to to
victimize you you are free when no one
is telling you what to do freedom in
other words is being left alone for the
left freedom is being given a bunch of
stuff once you have a bunch of stuff
that's what makes you free that is a
conflict envisions and that too will be
fought out in 2020 although honestly I
think the intersectional battle will
probably be fought out more prominently
in 2020 then the socialism versus
capitalism ideal because I think both
parties have fallen into the trap of
believing that the baseline of freedom
is a certain amount of material
prosperity which I don't think is true
freedom is not about material prosperity
material prosperity is the result of
freedom freedom is not the result of
material prosperity material prosperity
is the result of freedom meanwhile
Kamala Harris gave kind of a pre State
of the Union address in which she
basically tried to split the baby
between Stacey Abrams intersectionality
and Bernie Sanders socialism and she did
it you know pretty well I think she's
got to be seen as the front-runner in
the Democratic Party right now here's
her this is what her picture is gonna be
in 2020 I want everyone to remember this
the strength of our union has never been
found in the walls we build it's in our
diversity and our unity and that is our
power we also need our leaders to speak
truth about the threat of climate change
about our broken criminal justice system
about our weakened position in the world
and about the realities of racism sexism
anti-semitism homophobia and transphobia
okay so she's going full intersectional
first of all she's gonna need to explain
how our strength is in both our
diversity and our unity when the only
sort of diversity that she recognizes
his racial diversity she's gonna have to
explain that because it's true that
diversity can be a good thing in a
context where we have the same
and goals but she doesn't articulate any
of those common goals her common goal is
to divide us into these various
categories and then declare that
everybody is a victim group so that's
going to be her pitch in 2020 in other
words there's gonna be a very clear
conflict in 2020 you're gonna have to
pick a side Americans are gonna have to
pick a side is America based on
greatness are we rooted in greatness and
are we ever striving to reach the
eternal truth that the founders laid out
or is America based in evil vileness and
now we have to divide Americans into
little subgroups so that we can battle
it out and tear down that hierarchy
that's really the battle that we're
talking about now the media response to
all of this is insane and stupid the
number one piece over at the Washington
Post today is called queen of
condescending applause Nancy Pelosi
clapped at Trump and the internet lost
it so she's a hero for her clapping you
knew this was gonna happen right you
knew that before this ever happened it
was all gonna be about how Nancy Pelosi
was sophisticated she's the notorious
Nancy Pelosi what a man what up what a
woman she is standing up to a man like
Donald Trump by clapping politely Wow as
late-night host Seth Meyers reminded his
audience during Tuesday's special live
coverage of the speech there's a long
history of the people sitting behind the
president getting as much attention as
the president has himself this year says
the Washington Post was no exception in
a single fleeting moment shown only four
seconds on live broadcasts but
immortalized in photos and gifs Pelosi
became the Internet's newest obsession
for clapping Pelosi managed to limit her
reactions as subtle head shaking pursed
lips and eye roles were in Trump who's
been accused of exacerbating deep
divisions declared we must reject the
politics of revenge resistance and
retribution and embrace the boundless
potential of cooperation compromise in
the common good she appeared unable to
hold back rising from her seat along
with others in attendance Pelosi began
applauding with her arms oddly extended
out toward the president when Trump
turned toward her in the pair locked
eyes Pelosi still clapping appeared to
smirk oh man look at how she she showed
him with her clapping Wow and so this is
this is the media coverage well-done
media also you got a lo of objective
reporters like Anderson Cooper coming
back from Stacey Abrams his response to
the State of the Union here was Anderson
Cooper
it's been given by Stacey Abrams a
former gubernatorial candidate in the
state of Georgia I like that one better
so much journalism eh yeah just
journalism ago over the place they're
from Anderson Cooper very solid stuff so
the media obviously are gonna try and
twist what was a popular speech into an
unpopular speech by polling data corn
CNN snap poll 59% of Americans liked the
speech vast majority of independents
liked the speech according to a CBS News
poll it was 76% of Americans liked the
speech so now Democrats are going to try
and pick it apart pretend that it wasn't
good
pretend that it was actually divisive
and dark the media coverage is so wildly
biased that it's almost impossible to
parody and you know President Trump is
gonna have to fight against that which
means he's got to get on the campaign
trail that's exactly what he's doing
he's headed downtown Paso for his first
rally next week and he should he needs
to be on the campaign trail full-time
now because he's fighting not just
against the Democrats he is fighting
against a media that despises him okay
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like today I do love this story I love
it
so Elizabeth Warren has been spending
years saying she never called herself
Native American officially for any sort
of government benefit or for any reason
and she just would tell the story of how
she had a Native American heritage even
though she really didn't have Native
American heritage well yesterday it came
out that she did in fact identify
herself as a Native American for almost
two decades and there was a release of
her registration card for the State Bar
of Texas and it says directly on her
registration card signed by Elizabeth
Warren race American Indian so I want if
she filled out that form by calling
herself American Indian you think maybe
she did in some of her other official
forms that we are no longer able to
obtain maybe Anna Warren apologized
again so this is her second apology over
over all of this essentially her third
right she apologized a while back for
having made this an issue
Kwasi apologized for it then she
apologized after her ridiculous DNA test
and now she's apologizing for a third
time she says I can't go back but I am
sorry for furthering confusion on tribal
sovereignty and tribal citizenship and
harm that resulted well you are involved
in the Rachel Dolezal Rachel Dolezal of
Native American so that's probably a
career
ender for Elizabeth Warren well done
Elizabeth Warren ruined on the shoulders
of her own attempt to be part of the
intersectional Club we've been a fond
farewell to and and as the smoke signals
recede into the distance as she rides
across the plains of Oklahoma we say
goodbye to Elizabeth Warren okay other
things that I like today so if you're
just in the mood for some relaxation
today then pick up a bit of the
Beethoven Piano Concerto number one
second movement this is Vladimir
Ashkenazy playing it we just need a
little bit of soothing music don't you
think I think so here's a little bit
that
[Music]
so I could just play this for like
another hour this is fantastic but go
check it out yourself that is
Beethoven's piano concerto number one
second movement okay a couple of pieces
of breaking news that are just
spectacular
breaking news number one oh it's so
glorious it's so glorious mark herring
is the Attorney General of the state of
Virginia yes he's the Attorney General
of the state of Virginia
now let's recall Ralph Northam is in
serious trouble the governor of Virginia
why well number one he talked about
infanticide but no one cares about that
second there was a photograph in his
yearbook from 1985 in which either he or
one of his friends dressed in blackface
and either he or one of his friends is
dressed in a Ku Klux Klan outfit yeah
that was bad so then they're like okay
let's get rid of him then
Justin Fairfax is next in line right
he's the lieutenant governor of the
state and it turns out that he is in
mesh now in an accusation of sexual
sexual assault NBC News is reporting
just moments ago that virginia
lieutenant governor justin fairfax used
profane language in a private meeting
monday night while referring to his
accuser dr. Vanessa Tyson two sources
tell us Fairfax said of Tyson F that be
Ward yeah there's gonna go real well for
him so who's next in line after Justin
Fairfax like who's next
yesterday I suggested that it might be
gritty the Philadelphia Flyers mascot it
is not in fact it is the Attorney
General of the state of Virginia Amanda
mark herring so he would be next in line
also a Democrat one problem he released
a statement today he releases a
statement today and here's what it says
I am sure we have all done things at one
time and or another in our lives that
show poor judgment or worse yet have
caused some level of pain to others I
have a glaring example from my past that
I have thought about with deep regret in
the many years since and certainly each
time I took a step forward in public
service realizing that my goals in this
memory could someday collide and cause
pain for people I care about in 1980
when I was in nineteen year old
undergraduate in college some friends
suggested we attend a party dressed like
rappers we listened to at the time like
Kurtis Blow and perform a song it sounds
ridiculous even now writing it but
because of our ignorance and glib
attitudes and because we did not have an
appreciation for the experiences and
perspectives of others we dressed up and
put on wigs and brown makeup or no
so the Democrats and their no repentance
step Democrats and their no repentance
standard means that they're gonna get
rid of the governor and then they're
gonna get rid of the lieutenant governor
and then the Attorney General they're
gonna get rid of so whose fourth in line
anybody know like really Matt Walsh just
tweeted out okay fine I'll just be
governor of Virginia like man so
apparently I guess everybody in Virginia
just dressed up in blackface and like
the 1980s I guess that was like just a
thing everybody did
but again that's sort of the point right
that this was a thing that people they
were dressing up as various characters
like Michael Jackson or rappers because
people didn't think that that was racist
at the time because it may have been
racially insensitive and ignorant but it
wasn't racist at the time but now
because we have to judge everybody by
the standards of knowledge and
understanding and sensitivity we all
have now we're now going to toss out
every politician from the 1980s
well done Democrats so you've now
knocked out your own governor your own
lieutenant governor and now you're
Attorney General well done man
so Republicans it turns out don't even
have to win elections anymore all they
have to do is just wait for everyone who
is a Democrat who dressed up as a rapper
in 1982 to come out with that news solid
stuff right there oh man that's pretty
amazing
okay time for a thing that I hate so I
talked about this yesterday on my radio
show this is why I should subscribe so
you have access to my radio show but if
you don't talk about it again now Cory
Booker is just the worst Cory Booker is
a trash heap he's just a trash heap he
actually he over acts like Nicolas Cage
and has the intellect of a turnip Cory
Booker also happens to be a
discriminatory jackass when it comes to
religious people so Naomi Rao is a
nominee to the DC Circuit Court of
Appeals she's an Indian heritage and she
also happens to be a Christian
she was specifically asked by Cory
Booker about her views on the sinfulness
of homosexual activity this has nothing
to do with her job hey I view as a
religious person as a religious person
homosexual activities a sin
I also view premarital sex as a sin I
view adultery is a sin
I view breaking
Sabbath for a Jew is a sin right as a
religious person I have a lot of
feelings on sin does that have anything
to do with my public policy of course
not
does it have anything to do with even
Who I am friends with or people I
associate with no it has nothing to do
with those things but according to Cory
Booker if you're a religious person who
believes in the concept of sin therefore
you must be forcibly expelled from any
possibility of serving in the federal
government so here's cory booker
grilling i o'meara on her personal views
on the sinfulness of homosexuality or
gay relationships in your opinion
immoral senator I'm not sure you know
the relevance of that to you know I mean
I think that you relevant your opinion
if you think african-american
relationships are immoral do you think
gay relationships are immoral you
personally believe that a reaction I
dunno you do not believe that no you do
believe they're a sin senator you know
my personal views on any of these
subjects are things I would put to one
side and I would faithfully you're not
willing to say here fine that whether
what you're whether you believe it is
sinful for a man to men to be married
you're not you're not willing to comment
on that yeah senator yeah okay and the
answer is of course no of course no but
Cory Booker's a bigot and so he thinks
that if she believes something is sinful
therefore she can't be a federal judge
and later Ted Cruz said exactly that
like you're not allowed to do this the
Constitution forbids religious tests and
Cory Booker said I would die to protect
that woman's religious rights yeah you
go for it Spartacus yeah I'm sure I'm
sure captain googly-eyes Nicolas Cage
yeah I'm sure that you would die for her
rights it's a religious practice even
while you are condemning her her views
of sin I mean it's just gross it's just
gross now the truth is I mean this
occurred to me last night when thinking
about this that Cory Booker is actually
using his own views of sin as a
substitute for Naomi rouse what I mean
by that is that religious people believe
a lot of people commit a lot of sins and
that you can still have relationships
with them you can still talk with them
you don't have to embed your views of
sin and public policy religious people
believe all these things but Democrats
believe that if something is a sin the
government should forbid it they believe
that if something is a saint if
something is bad the government should
step in and stop it
so he I really think that Cory Booker
fully cannot comprehend how Niomi around
could think homosexual activity is a sin
and also not be interested in having the
government stop him
sexual activity because when you believe
that government is God and it's God's
job to punish sin you don't understand
how it is that somebody else could
believe something is a sin and the
government has no role at all
so cory booker being a religious bigot
well done democrats this is this is your
party now
so congratulations all right well we
will be back here later with two hours
of live coverage presumably we will find
out who is fourth in line from Virginia
Governor in in because now we've gone
through the the governor lieutenant
governor and the AG so pretty much it's
just a random dude walking around in
Alexandria today he's gonna be governor
of Virginia's that's really exciting
they should just hold like a lottery or
a sweepstakes or something they should
they should actually I think they should
just maybe pick a person out of a crowd
like The Hunger Games well actually just
have a lottery and then we'll see who
gets picked pretty awesome stuffing
provision you'll bring you all the
updates later this is why you should
subscribe if not we will see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19